an obsessive Aunt skirting ciao labor
law regulations and a pilot that's tough
to revisit underneath all that family
fun are some questionable things we
ignore in Bob's Burgers
throughout the Run of Bob's Burgers
there are constant mentions of and
examples pointing to one indisputable
fact the belchers are very poor whenever
Mr Fish odor stops by for whatever
reason there is always a mention of Bob
and Linda being late on rent and if
there was any doubt about this fact the
characters even Bob and Linda's kids say
it all the time but after watching the
show for years you start to wonder how
this family has any money at all most
episodes show that the status quo for
the restaurant is vacancy especially
compared to the more successful Jimmy
pestos across the street surely the lack
of patrons outside of Teddy and one or
two straight customers an episode is
concerning there is the occasional Boom
Like The Fan animated brunch Squatch
episode but a rare busy night is surely
not enough to feed a family the fact
that the kids stay in the same grade and
never age means that none of these
questions really matter but adult
viewers still have to suspend their
disbelief just a little bit some of the
best parts of Bob's Burgers are the
little details and recurring gags for
example fans from familiar with the show
know the lookout for the storefront next
to the restaurant and the moving van
that appears in each opening credit
sequence another consistently funny bit
is the Burger of the day which always
changes and is always a pun whether it's
the Texas Chainsaw massacred burger or
the graters of the sauce havarti Burger
there is one thing that never changes on
the board the price for over a dozen
Seasons now the burger of the day has
remained 5.95 regardless of the
ingredients or the absurd amount of work
Bob must put into coming up with a new
idea and product each day it Remains the
Same price the rest of the menu has
stayed the same too from season 1 to
season 12 Burgers remain five dollars
while fries and soft drinks will run you
two dollars each these prices were a
bargain in 2011 and are even more
unbelievable today for those with
particularly Keen eyes you might also
notice the belchers still have beer on
the menu for four dollars despite the
restaurant almost never selling in it
the belches are unable to hire any
additional employees thanks to their
dismal financial situation so instead
all three of Bob and Linda's children
are put to work maybe Bob wants to keep
it a family business but more often than
not it seems the kids cause more harm
than good in the restaurant the show
normalizes the kids working so much it's
easy to forget that you don't see
children working every day technically
minors in the United States are legally
allowed to work in a business owned by
their parents as long as they aren't
missing school by this standard the
Belcher kids putting in a few hours of
work each night after school isn't
illegal ugh school again punching in for
another day of unpaid child labor before
we go home and do more on paid child
labor however safety is another concern
there are laws and precautions that
apply specifically to restaurants
employing children that say they cannot
operate or be near dangerous equipment
like a fryer or grill basically every
time we see the belchers have a family
meeting in the kitchen while Bob Cooks
up Burgers and Fries that is probably
breaking some kind of child safety law
which is to say nothing of all the
restaurant hijinks the kids get up to
behind Bob and Linda's back this has
been an ongoing issue since the show's
start that has never really been
addressed and at this point it's such a
renowned characteristic of the show it
will probably never change two of the
three women in the lead voice cast of
Bob burgers are voiced by men Linda is
voiced by John Roberts and Tina by Dan
mint Louise voiced by Kristen Shaw is
the only member of the family voiced by
a woman I had a very
today he did yeah he's an interesting
guy yeah he is very interesting Tina
although this isn't a deal breaker by
any means it could be a frustrating
aspect to female fans of the show even
more frustrating is the fact that
according to uprox as recently as 2020
Creator Lauren Bouchard doesn't seem to
see an issue with the casting it isn't
too taboo to cast a voice actor who
doesn't match the character's gender
especially on children shows but it is
extremely prevalent in Bob's Burgers in
addition to voicing Bob H John Benjamin
will often voice minor characters and
episodes including a major recurring
female character Louise's teacher Miss
Labonte while many of these characters
have achieved icon status their acting
is just a little questionable it might
be time to start thinking about Gail's
obsession with her sister's husband it's
no secret that Gail has the hots for Bob
this awkward pairing has led to some of
the series best episodes but seriously
Gail's burning passion for Bob is
getting a bit creepy don't you think you
ruined my Thanksgiving dinner because
you wanted a 10 no I ruined your
Thanksgiving dinner because I wanted
attention oh wait is that what you said
Gail is Linda's awkward single cat
loving sister and she has a bit of a
crush on Bob it's an awkward situation
that would definitely need some serious
working out in real life thankfully
Bob's Burgers is a cartoon so Gail can
still be sympathetic and not some kind
of home-wrecking monster plus Bob isn't
the only man in her life at a certain
point in the show Gail and Wagstaff
counselor Mr frond date in the season 5
episode father of the Bob we get our
first big glimpse into Bob's childhood
home life he never had the greatest
relationship with his father Big Bob
especially after a traumatic Burger
related event when Bob was a boy the two
reconnect in the episode and reach a
resolution but there is a huge missing
link that is only briefly explained who
was Bob's mother and where is she in the
episode there is a line that implies
Bob's mother died when he was a young
child and this is part of the reason his
relationship with his father became so
strained she has only mentioned one
other time in a later episode Barbara
calls that he used to build gingerbread
houses with his mom before she passed
throughout the show Tina yearns for the
love of Jimmy Jr and his backside this
pushes her to try and be included in his
friend group of popular teams despite
the fact that they constantly berate and
Bully her still they managed to get up
to plenty of hijinks together and over
the course of the show Tina's
relationship with her bullies changes
into something more resembling
friendship Tammy and Jocelyn are the
meanest satina as evident in an episode
like broadcast wax staff School news
where Tina is excluded from the school
news while Tammy succeeds as anchor in
episodes like this Tina is the odd one
out of the group and even Zeke and Jimmy
Jr are in her friends however in more
recent episodes Tina is treated almost
like one of the group judging by the
fact that no one ages in the show
viewers can assume time does not
progress linearly in Bob's Burgers
regardless of this fact it seems that as
we watch the show Tina seems to be
forming actual bonds with her peers and
does indeed consider them friends the
season 2 episode Burger boss features
Bob at his most obsessive when he
recovers an old arcade game he used to
be a master at Bob starts spending every
waking moment trying to top The
Machine's high score he plays until he
develops carpal tunnel syndrome and is
prescribed painkillers for his wrist the
weird part comes when Linda sends the
machine to a local arcade first Bob
tries to enter the arcade without his
children but is told he needs to bring
them so Bob brings the kids along and
immediately starts ignoring them in
favor of the burger boss machine that's
bad parenting strike number one his
second mistake is to team up with
another kid named Daryl who gives Bob
tips on how to play the game with one in
particular raising some eyebrows why are
you standing way back you got a pressure
winner against the game like this see
yeah okay all right oh yeah wow
eventually Daryl offers to help in
exchange for Bob beating up the bullies
that terrorize him this leads to an
extremely awkward scene where Bob high
on painkillers attempts to beat up the
bullies and fortunately all fails Bob's
Burgers gives the impression that Calvin
fishholder is the richest man alive at
least compared to every other character
we meet in the still unnamed town the
cartoon is set in fish odor is a
property owner a narcissist and probably
a billionaire while we don't have a list
of everything he owns his attitude
points to the conclusion that fish odor
is more or less the most powerful man in
town what it's horrible you don't like a
ticket up with Mr Fish odor he owns the
cups for starters he is the belcher's
landlord implying he owns many retail
and housing units we know he owns the
Wonder Wharf amusement park and baseball
teams and we know that his Mansion is
immense what we don't know is how fish
odor is legally allowed to own so much
property in such a seemingly small
community he is definitely breaking some
anti-competition laws here and Bob's
Burgers isn't afraid to make fish older
a villain and put him up to some scummy
stuff even so the worst of the tycoon's
dealings likely happens behind the
scenes the first season of Bob's Burgers
contain contains a series of the show's
most offensive and inappropriate jokes
for example the show's pilot notably
titled human flesh includes a series of
jokes and plot points that make the
possibility that the belchers are
cannibals seem relatively tank it all
starts when Health Inspectors Hugo and
Ron come to inspect the restaurant and
Louise decides to have some fun with the
burger of the day the burger of the day
is the child molester
get it yes well later in the episode a
customer Bob says looks like a child
molester winds up ordering a burger Bob
then tells Gene to serve him his food
making the fat phobic comment that cinch
Gene is Heavy He's Less in danger of
being harmed by the creepy customer
in the same scene Gene tries to
volunteer Tina to run the food since
she's the oldest however bobbin says
Gene do it because Tina isn't great with
customers prompting the kids to protest
I'm good with a customer not really I'm
great with the customers she's autistic
she can't help it yeah I'm autistic Bob
just a sec no you're not autistic Tina
to drive the controversial Point home
the rest of the scene shows Gene
throwing toothpicks on the floor for
Tina to count in a parody of the film
Rainman which is about an autistic
Savant the first season of Bob's Burgers
is definitely the most raunchy and
finding an identity that would keep it
on Fox for over a decade the show wasn't
always quite as family friendly as it is
now in particular the episode sheesh cat
Bob contains a plot line that reinforces
negative stereotypes about trans people
in this episode Bob becomes a cab driver
to make some extra cash and ends up
picking up a group of trans sex workers
throughout the episode there's some
questionable stereotype about both sex
workers and trans people and jokes that
get a laugh out of misgendering these
characters so much so that the line
between whether the show is saying the
characters or cross-dressers or actually
trans is blurred
[Music]